[Music]
it is beautiful out here Christina
and I see your chicken
veneers does he really exist he's coming
he's coming with his baby
girl oh she's she's a big girl these are
my two loves right here Christina was
this a package deal Stella Josh Stella
was also love at first sight yeah still
is my girl she's the sweetest doggie and
the kids love her she sleeps in bed with
the boys it's the whole thing so on
right now she's just preoccupied because
the chicken smells chicken yeah it just
smells dinner no no no those are pets
yes those are our friends how much do
you love this woman I love her more than
anything well it's pretty equal just
Velma
home is where the heart is and these
newly we've made this sprawling 23 Acres
six bedroom floor
outside Nashville their love nest
how much you love in Nashville these
days uh I love it I mean this is kind of
where I feel at home yeah I mean
wherever she is I feel at home but like
having her here and now my dog here at
the same time this is heaven truly
Heaven is blown oh I get up every
morning and just get to work I'm like I
can't wait to work on the property any
time that we can get the kids out here
for an extended weekend that's exactly
what we do they always have a blast
Christy and Josh's Modern Family also
includes her two children with
ex-husband tarikal Musa 12 year old
Taylor and seven-year-old Braden and
three-year-old Hudson who she shares
with X and instead he's such a guy's guy
you'll find him out here chopping wood
making wood for our fire I even wearing
flannel oh are you kidding me this is
the first one that I've worn that
actually has sleeves I usually cut them
on and you'll see all that plus some
pretty epic home renovations when their
new series Christina in the country
debuts on HGTV how's my bullet so what
kind of convincing did it take for you
to join the reality TV team here with
Christina you'll be a part of the show
together if there was a business aspect
I was in let her be the beautiful face
and the talent let me do most of the
business and I'll pop in here and there
and show my support but other than that
I like doing the business part so good
how are you finding your footing with TV
though uh it's not bad I mean the the
good thing is the crew are amazing she's
worked with a lot of them for several
years to move them I think 10 or more
years and they they took me in my family
they know that she loves me I love her
they recognize that and everybody treats
me really well so as long as I feel like
it's a family Dynamic and not a
production yeah it's easy so Josh I feel
like this is going to be your
introduction to a lot of Christina's
fans what do you want people to know
about you who is Josh uh I've always
been a pretty private person obviously
she's a public figure getting with her
we had to find a happy medium where
we've chosen what we want to share more
or less we keep all the intimate
personal stuff private in between us and
when we share something that's a small
part of our life but it's enough to let
people know like Hey we're here we're
together we're enjoying life and we do
love each other are you designing a
chicken Cooper yes I got to see one of
their first Nashville projects together
this Swanky Chicken Coop Castle
[Music]
come here girl all right I want to show
you my mini rooster
so that's not a baby
that's a full-grown rooster
I think they're called Royals
he's a little confused uh his his lady
friend is still inside oh his lady
friend's right here now there's this one
so that that's his lady friend a little
one we call that one chicken nugget this
little thing kind of her
it's a beautiful specimen right here
you are a polite Southern girl right I
don't know what would she get her head
into I don't know
yes my heart's happy you said everything
in life has led you to where you want to
be right now how so what is bringing you
so much joy at this stage in your life I
think just so lucky to have the coast to
coast life right Josh this is where he
feels very comfortable is in Tennessee
again we have our family here but also
just enjoying the coast life we have the
best time in Newport as well bike riding
enjoying the beach we have a great
property there we have our friends and
family there but then traveling to
Tennessee we just have those relaxing
Southern Vibes and just feeling like
relaxed settled
all the Good Vibes so what is country
Christina like versus Coastal Christina
I think I'm bringing some of my Coastal
vibe to the country we have a lot of
transplants in Franklin Tennessee
welcome to your new kitchen
oh gosh it's a five-star hotel
this is crazy man so we're getting like
a very eclectic clients right like we
have musicians we have songwriters so
it's not just like what you might expect
of just seeing like modern Farmhouse or
the country Flair like we're
incorporating a lot of really cool
Styles here a lot of very unique Styles
actually I think more unique than what
I'm doing in California really yes
because you have people from all walks
of life yeah that we're working with not
just your country music artists but have
you ever had to do like a jam Jam room
or a recording studio yet not yet we
were supposed to and we were hoping that
happened so season two that would be so
amazing
[Music]
this home gives me so many good vibes
how did you want to put your touch but
with like a little bit of a country
Flair and scrub to it it's always having
that modern Farmhouse touch when we
bought this house it was all white so we
added the black Vibes I like that like
Moody element and actually a lot of the
houses that we're doing in Christina in
the country surprisingly have a lot of
that Moody Vibe oh so more Moody less
boho or a nice balance between boho and
Moody a nice balance it's like not too
Moody because then it could be like a
little depressing yeah that was like the
balance right yeah and just it touches
like I like different elements like how
you see the different Stones the
textures the textures yeah did the kids
show any interest in wanting to follow
in your footsteps when it comes to
design and real estate and things like
that oh Taylor is a little designer it's
kind of in her DNA Braden he is more
adventurous he's old boy right now he's
in soccer football jiu jitsu's Hudson
he's three he's a little genius so
we'll see life is full right now more
kids in the future for you and Josh I
know our hands are full shelving that
right now right so new place new chapter
new series and you're introducing Josh
into the world of reality tv as well so
how did the two of you navigate what you
share and what you keep sacred yes
that's a very good question
um Josh and I are also executive
producers on both shows so there is many
hours of communication as far as what we
want to share what we keep for ourselves
we didn't film The Wedding for example
that won't be on television it's just
it's constant communication
we haven't seen you since you got
hitched in Maui so big congrats you
looked stunning and was it just a
magical day for you yeah it was just our
our closest family and friends very
small 40 people it was raining which I
heard it's good luck when we first
initially talked about you know him
appearing on the show I made it just 100
like it's always us first we are the
priority and whatever else is second of
course you know us and the kids so it's
just anything that's fun you're only
going to see things that are fun it's we
have a great time doing it and it's it's
just real like what you see here is is
real life right it's really what we're
doing and it's it's tons of Adventures
it's Fresh Starts it's been an amazing
journey
foreign